or got a thesis what can you say about
when you are given a network or you are
given a composite system and you want to
try and figure out what it's made off
and so this is the type of problem that
I'd like to address and I don't really
have so far a definite formal framework
for this problem so it's more like some
kind of preliminary ideas on but i do
have wishes in this paper mm-hmm a
framework for one particular type or one
particular flavor of network namely call
still network space in networks and so
i'll talk about this particular case a
little bit in the second half okay so
basically the problem setting is this if
you are given the observed behavior of
some kind of system which is a black box
to you you don't know it's inside that
box you only know the external observed
behavior then what can you say about the
internal structure of the box about what
sort of network is inside the box um and
so to just rephrase this problem make it
more precise in the simplest manner I'd
like to address the question of given
some particular hypothesis about the
structure of the Oregon side of the box
is this hypothesis feasible this is
possible to explain the observed
behavior with this particular network
topology and so this is the kind of
problem that comes up when you do kind
of hacking or reverse engineering
systems right then you you can't look
inside you just can prove it from the
outside and you want to reproduce it you
want to rebuild a thing then it's
helpful to have some idea about what's
in what could be inside but also this is
actually from a slightly different
perspective in some sense it's all about
complexity theory so this is a basically
about circuit complexity right when you
when you want to in this case
have an observed behavior of the
composite system but you have more
likely desired a desired behavior for
the complicit system and you asking
yourself can I realize that can I
achieve the society havior using a
limited number of components this is
kind of complexity theory circuit
complexity and so this also maybe I can
refer back to my title slide and maybe
if you're from my generation or maybe a
little bit older you might remember this
video game called The Incredible Machine
where you have a bunch of components
which are here on the right and then you
are in this situation and you have to
achieve the desired behavior which in
this case is to get the mouse safely
into this part and so in this case all
this works is that you can use the
trampoline to kind of make this bowling
ball destroy the fishbowl that will
attract the CAD and there's a sensor
wheel which you can connect to the
conveyor belt and that will make the
mouse kind of be projected to here and
then it will be scared of the cat and so
on really yeah yeah so this is this is
this type of role tonight we have some
overall desired behavior and we have a
bunch of components and the question is
whether we can implement that behavior
using these components and so to do this
a little bit more formally again I'm
also going to use the framework of
symmetric monoidal categories so for me
also a system as some morphism in some
suitable symmetric manolo category okay
so let me make an example of what this
hypothesis about an internal structure
might look like so suppose that you have
some kind of system which has two inputs
five Alec puts and you know about this
what is overall behavior is so you have
you are given some kind of particular
morphism with this two inputs and five
outputs and you wonder yourself
and you wonder can I write this morphism
asked the composite off let's say
something of some smaller Marxism that
may look like this and wire together in
some way looking like this just a kind
of random example too and ok so here I'm
can already read off some necessary
conditions a particular here you can say
that whatever comes out here I should
not depend on what goes in here right
because there's no wire going from the
left to the right part so this is a
certain is certainly a necessary
condition that the overall morphism must
actually factor into a model product but
this is far from necessary and so later
on I'll show some sorry this is far from
sufficient later on I'll show some
additional necessary constraints that
must be satisfied but before that let me
say something a little bit about the
general structure of this type of
problem and how much we can actually
expect to be able to say at all because
it says it sounds like it's impossible
to say what's inside if you're in an
audio source behavior right and I sort
of join with the claim that it is
possible observing the inputs the
outputs and the causal dependencies no
you don't know sir fracaso dependencies
you only observe so the overall behavior
which is like for an electrical circuit
for example it would be you you know
what the currents are when you put a
certain distribution of potentials at
but only at these external ports
fiddle with one and what you got a
fiddle with all of them but only with
Vegas external ones so you have some for
can't make impossible out being put to
you know the odds um yes it's basically
you know what this morphism is in the
corresponding symmetric monoidal
category ver this thing takes its
semantics so yeah in the case that I'm
going to explain later in the case of
causal inference these are this is takes
place in the category of stochastic
matrices or equivalently speaking of
finite sets of objects and stochastic
maps we can finite sets s morphisms and
then yeah then you would know the
distribution over the outputs for any
values of the inputs okay but yet so let
me say a little bit though at what I
think one can actually and for how much
one can expect to infer um so first of
all what is actually the structure of
the set of these of the feasible
hypotheses so by feasible I mean that
the hypothesis about the internal
structure would coach you have generated
the observed behavior okay so certainly
lower you can take the turtle hypothesis
but the network inside just looks like
this just like a box that you can't
decode post any folder and this one
always works because this can explain
any observe behavior any any morphism
with two inputs and five output system
artisan with two inputs and five outputs
but it's nonsense it's also the least
interesting one current because we would
typically I got to prefer any other
explanation over this one okay so
there's some other operations that one
can apply to one particular 21 feasible
hypotheses and get another feasible
hypothesis
whoa no faces the black boxing so we've
already heard a little bit of a black
boxing which just means that you take
some subnetwork let's say this here and
you want to consider this as a single
morphism just say okay let's say so
these individual boxes and I group some
of them together in the nest I want to
consider this subset of boxes as a black
box by itself so then why I need to be
careful about what are the inputs and
what are the outputs of this new box so
we have to have to kind of bridge all
these a little bit and so if I apply
this like boxing operation anywhere to a
feasible hypothesis then certainly again
got a feasible hypothesis right because
then I still have a network topology
that can generate my observed behavior
so this is one operation that always
works another one is that if you start
with these simple hypothesis you can add
additional wires anywhere I'd will still
be a fusible hypothesis right yeah so
under these two operations you can take
the set of all these wiring diagrams we
were short of hypotheses I happened as I
said I haven't really made any of these
things very formally odd these are just
sort of some some preliminary ideas ya
know and about you yeah yeah yeah but
you have to remember these are not
particular morphisms these are kind of
blueprints of this is this is basically
a formal string diagram not it's not
instantiated your iPhone your particular
morphisms
so yeah these are just abstract kind of
wiring diagrams on and with the right
number of input and output wires and I
considered a set of Foley's wiring
diagrams and under these two operations
of black boxing and adding wires this
defines the it is actually partially
already set I would say I go lower in
the order if I apply these operations so
the stuff that's high in the order i
would i would say these sort of complex
explanations through this which contain
really fine structure and work and so
then no I would well it's conventional
that I'm not sure I mean I open to but I
was thinking more in terms of a sort of
DCP o-type thinking or something where
higher complexity or more structure
means to google upwards and we're kind
of refinement refinement goes upwards so
that's yeah ok yeah ok yeah right yeah
good point ok so in my current
convention it goes downwards but maybe
it maybe it's better to make it go up or
so i don't know i mean this kind of a
Vettori um yeah but in any case it
defines the partial ordering um and so
we gotta post that which is kind of
parametrized by the number of inputs and
outputs of the wiring diagrams that
we're considering and then also
certainly depends on the particular
flavor off monoidal category that one
considers so we could use my diagrams
for symmetric manolo categories for
Trey's compact or whatever on and I
haven't really been very specifically
but I think a general idea should should
apply to all of these ok enough on one's
to do so one can also introduce a set of
types for the wires
so you can say for example in circuit
complexity well I really want each wire
to be a bit and not an arbitrary kind of
system and so in this case when one can
impose or label these wires with
additional types but one doesn't need to
in which case the wires should be
allowed to carry arbitrary objects okay
so then the feasible hypotheses as I was
saying are our stable and our black
boxing and on our additional adding
additional wires so this means that we
have a lower set in this post set and
this is basically what I was what I
wanted to say about how much one can
expect to be able to infer we certainly
can tell the exact structure of network
outs inside because there's always a
trivial hypotheses hypothesis but the
feasible hypotheses just for him this
lower set yeah and maybe when we would
say that well the best explanation for
what's inside is kind of the one which
is the maximal element of this lower set
so it's the most fine-grained one so the
one the one which is most predictive in
a sense that it would be able to explain
the least amount of other behave
potential behaviors so to apply this
kind of reasoning one would like to have
this lower set would like the slower
start you have a maximal element yeah I
don't know ander what conditions when
can expect this to be the case okay so
now let me say something about how one
can approach this kind of problem so so
far so soon talking about the problem
itself the problem setting and now I'd
like to introduce a technique for
actually solving this problem in some
cases and the cases that I can deal with
or to which this technique applies are
those in which one else
normal category solutions offshore just
a terminal object so if you don't know
what it means that don't worry about it
so this basically she's saying that one
came to scarred systems but there's the
way to just take a wire and so that I
want to ignore this output and so I'm
going to denote this by this kind of
black dot here just me just discard the
system and this is the important
property that if I apply some morphism
deuced do something and then discard
that's the same as justice guarding from
the outset and this is sort of what
makes this inflation technique work okay
so in the particular case for which I
would like to show the examples of this
technique I think I don't have to time
to introduce any kind of generalities
but so I'll just illustrate this
technique with examples and in this case
the category C is going to be this
category so casting matrices or
stochastic maps between finite sets and
so in this case string diagrams and see
all are basically the same thing as
what's called Bayesian networks you know
of this happened to term and there's a
bit of a solid layer which yeah that I'm
kind of slightly lying a little bit but
we'll see more about this later and so
this is something that was actually
worked out in detail by Brendan okay so
yeah now let me go to these two examples
of the method and so the first example
is that imagine that you have a black
box which is not hell which is not half
in inputs but it only has outwards there
are three outputs and so in psychotic
matrices that means that it will
generate some observed distribution on
three random variables and so let's just
let's say that this surf distribution is
perfect correlation between these three
variables and these are able start
Winery so that equality is 0 and 1 and
there are a uniformly distributed but
perfectly correlated that's kind of you
got 0 the probability one-half and then
all of them are zero or you got 1 with
probability one-half for all of them
yeah so now we could try to explain the
subsurface behavior using this kind of
network topology so this would be saying
that you have what income and causal
inference would be called you have a
common ancestor for each two of them but
notably there's no there's no morphism
or anything that that would result would
eventually connect to all three of them
but we only have terrorized things
you're going on whatever information
flow happens here it can only end up in
two of these at a time and this is kind
of how to how to think of this network
and this is also the intuitive reason
for why this hypothesis is not feasible
for this absurd behavior you cannot
generate this distribution from this
kind of network and yeah so let me prove
this
and the way to prove this is that I will
take this network or take the components
of the network really and take a bunch
of copies of them and rewire them in a
different way and so this looks like
this so there's this essay see here I've
taken two copies of this and what I'm
doing is basically I'm moving one copy
to the left and then moving another
coffee to the right oh and then I yeah
get a new network it looks like this and
here I'm just discarding one half of
this what comes out of this source
markeson okay and so this is a kind of
network we call an inflation or an
inflated network yeah and no we can try
to infer something about the behavior
about the observed behavior of this
network from the observed behavior of
this original one so are you expecting
perfect correlations between the two
copies of the essay a be between the two
copies of si si but between this one and
this one yes no so these are actually
independent so there is nothing so this
this comes mathematically this comes
from the monoidal structure which is
given by just well parallel composition
means you that things operate
independently so in probabilistic
courtesies are independent and this is
important and let's coming up
so from the old search behavior here I
can make some inferences or derive some
constraints about the observed behavior
if this hypothetical network could be
and then these are is crucial
observations here so if i look at this
hypothetical inflated network and i
discard see then i can apply this back
propagation of of that discarding
operation and then this part will just
completely disappear so that means that
i'm basically looking at a subnetwork
that looks that corresponds to this left
half on yeah like this and the important
observation is that this looks exactly
like taking this original Network and
discarding see here and then applying
the back propagation the only difference
is that move the sacc to the left but
that's just notation okay so that's
clear yes and the other crucial
observation is that if i take this new
network and discard be then again i
apply the back propagation here and this
disconnects into two components which
are not independent so this translates
into probabilistic independence okay so
now this means that we have derived we
have to write some conditions on but you
observe behavior ABC of the new network
can possibly be on and so first the
first observation is that a and B have
the same behavior or the same observed
distribution as in the original network
because of this because in both cases
that those are solution is generated by
this network so by perfectly
uncorrelated you
I mean perfectly a quarterly sorry yeah
I guess it's hopeful yeah and likewise
for VNC and finally we have this
independence that when we discard be
then disconnects so this implies that a
and C must be independent yeah but now I
saw these constraints are so strong that
are actually inconsistent there is no
China solution which has all of these
properties and this implies that well
the assumption that we started with
namely that this was the feasible
hypotheses hypothesis must have been
wrong to begin with so this is the basic
idea of the method yes yeah well in this
case i'm using the property that well
i'm mainly using that's the unit of
sugars terminal
his first bite I mean
[Music]
this one yeah yeah so that seems like a
specific this is only now for kind of to
make it easy to understand but I can
formulate a general technique it's
basically a kind of martial problem or
maybe you would call it chief theoretic
contacts chirality again but it's
independent of which model yes yes one
can make sense of this in any somatic
monoidal category bird unit object is
terminal so there are marshmallow
problem would mean that you have a
morphism or yeah you know you want to
infer what a morphism is which has a
bunch of outputs when you know what the
morphism is we know just after
discarding some of these outputs
basically given a family of marshalls
and you want to know which are in
distribution is the stick we can make
sense of in any symmetric Manolo
category with discarding right and so
that's the general that would be the
general technique yeah but this actually
has additional structure which is also
useful that one can make copies of
systems so this is a kind of related to
this hyper graph categories that have
heard about earlier although it's a
custom matrices are not a hypergraph
category but only kind of half of it
innocence we can only make we can make
copies of systems just copy it you can
take a random variable and just copy
this value and this will you know I will
draw this kind of marshes in like this
so this equips every object with a
kimono structure together with sort of
discarding operation being the co unit
and yeah so one can make use of this for
this inflation technique to make it more
powerful and meaning that one can write
on more inflated networks inflated
networks which also contain this copying
operation and so yeah I'd like to
present an example of how this works on
and this is actually well known to some
of the people here who study things like
Bell's Theorem so this is now a
stochastic matrix or a conditional
probability distribution which takes two
inputs and two outputs and so let's say
all these variables are binary and so
I'm kind of using motu arithmetic here
so this is kind of XOR and if you want
to turn our bits and here it is
multiplication so this is a conditional
distribution which if both x and y are
one and this evaluates to 1 that means
that this a plus B equals one holds
whenever a and B are different while if
one of them is at least one of them
takes two values 0 then the civility is
20 and then in more to arithmetic that
means that this condition holds if and
only if I and B are the same and
actually we should have been a half note
a quarter yeah so when at least one of
them text value is 0 then what comes out
here is a perfect correlation between a
and B and and again kind of unbiased
binary variables while if both of them
have to value 1 then what comes out here
is perfect anti correlation yeah and so
now the hypothesis would be that that
this observed behavior is generated by
this sort of network topology it seems
kind of may be reasonable to to begin
with because if you discard for example
a you look at this network topology
that that means that the speed cannot
depend on X and so this is certainly the
case here if you take the marginal over
a then B is just uniformly random no
matter what X is so it doesn't depend on
X
so in the from this perspective it looks
promising but it's actually the whole
hypothesis is still not feasible but now
this meets something a little bit more
sophisticated to show and so this is
actually what's known as Bell's Theorem
sort of so I'm not saying really
anything new but maybe it's just an a
from a bit of a different perspective
yeah and so the inflation network that
one can use to show this infeasibility
would look like this you take this
original morphism lambda here and you
apply this kimono etch the copying
operation here on yeah on both of these
wires um and so then you take copies of
these boxes um and construct this new
inflated network yeah and now I again
make some inferences about the possible
behavior of this network from the
assumed behavior of the original one and
so this is as follows um if we put in
plug in particular values here let's say
we take this to be 0 we take this to be
a zero and we take this to be one and
this to be one then that must result
okay maybe I should have phrased this in
a bit more little bit differently but
yeah so okay if we discard a a knot here
and we discard to be not then again we
can do the back for vacation on off of
this Co unit and we'll find that again
we are left with a network that looks
just like the original one so the
observed behavior regarding only a1 and
b1 is exactly the same as in original
and I likewise for a knot and be one for
example or actually for any one of the
four possible combinations of taking one
of these days and one of these fees
let's do the same behavior is an
original one and so now in addition to
this i'm going to plug in particular
values for these input variables yeah
and if i plug in these particular values
while i will get only a child abuse you
know these four variables and by what i
had but i was just saying about
discarding on one of these this observed
distribution will have to probably that
this a knot and Abby not are perfectly
correlated any marginal distribution
after I have discarded a1 and b1
likewise be not an a.1 are perfectly
correlated a 1 and V naught are
perfectly correlated sorry this is again
no typos and finally be 1 and a 1 are
perfectly correlated anti-correlated
yeah I'm not sure if this is clear but
at least the basic idea has kind of
become here yeah and again one can show
that there is no distribution of four
variables that would have these
properties and so hence we have an
infeasible hypothesis yeah so this is a
basic outline of the technique by
example um yeah and that's that's all
thanks
any questions James of do you have a
good sense for what and these were ad
hoc examples right on that sense of the
general power of this technique what
sort of things can you move out or is it
hard yeah it seems hard to make general
statements um I guess the most obvious
question is whether if you apply this no
to all inflated networks you get
necessary and sufficient conditions for
feasibility and this seems not to be the
case but we don't have a formal proof
but yeah magical step is we're at the
end you say oh there's no distribution
with these properties right those mean
that that don't mean that's that really
matters right yeah yeah what are they
all met him in there but these all steps
can also be a generalized I mean you can
make sense of these in all symmetric
manolo categories with discarding and
possibly with copying um but I can't
really say much about how powerful the
technique actually is certainly it gives
necessary conditions and we're probably
not sufficient ones in general and a
case of causal inference it also depends
a lot on we can derive additional
constraints that did not work they do
not generalize to other symmetric manama
categories and that also makes it more
powerful there but we don't know whether
anything becomes sufficiently innocence